good evening I think we can do a little
better than that can't we good evening
all right I don't have a voice like the
announcer but luckily you won't have to
listen to me all night we're here for
Jamal Joseph and I want to and i'd like
to welcome all of you tonight i'm dori
and more and an assistant professor here
and political science the school of
international public affairs and in
african-american studies and the first
thing I'd like to do is to say thank you
to a number of people first the School
of the Arts where Professor Joseph is
film faculty member the institute for
research in african-american studies
this event you should know is being
webcast live courtesy of the columbia
alumni association we will have impact
who's in the house impact will be
performing at the end of our discussion
and Q&A quite a treat i'd also like to
finally last but not least thank the
crew of the Miller center of the miller
theatre rather so a quick word about the
format tonight Professor Joseph will
talk for about 20 minutes about his
fantastic book Panther baby and then
we'll have a discussion between
Professor Joseph and myself with regrets
Afeni Shakur could not make it tonight
but she sends her love so we'll have a
conversation Professor Joseph and myself
followed by QA we'll open it up for
about another 15 minutes and then a
performance by impact followed by a book
signing and the lobby and i should say
if you have not picked
your copy of Panther baby there will be
plenty of opportunity there are plenty
of books outside after the event tonight
it is a compelling compelling amazing
book I could not put it down when I
start it and I think we'll hear a little
bit about it tonight so let me introduce
our main event professor Jamal Joseph is
associate professor at the film program
here at Columbia University School of
the Arts professor joseph has written
and directed for Black Stars HBO fox TV
New Line Cinema Warner Brothers and A&E
he wrote and directed drive by a love
story the zone and the docudrama Hughes
dreams Harlem for black stars he
recently finished the screenplay for and
will direct Panther baby for Focus
Features
the book in the movie is based on his
true life experiences as one of the
youngest members of the Black Panther
Party Professor Joseph is the author of
Tupac legacy he has also written the
script for a Broadway musical based on
the life of Tupac Shakur he is the
founder and artistic director of impact
a Harlem based impact is a Harlem base
Youth Theatre Company he's also
executive director of new heritage films
a not-for-profit organization that
provides training and opportunities for
minority filmmakers with no further ado
please join me in welcoming professor
Jamal Joseph
thank you there's so much love in the
room I feel so great a beanie and I were
in communication texting texting back
and forth this morning she really tried
to come she's very very under the
weather and when her direct flight she
was coming from North Carolina when her
direct flight from charlotte to New York
I'd cancelled she just understood that
her body could not deal with the later
flight and that was also a connecting
flight in the layover and I also on the
tour you'll see me I'm running a little
bit of a fever even as I stand here on
the tour there was the beginning of this
tour was from LA to Seattle to Boise to
DC and back thought I had the flu and
kept getting worse and then in boys I
got bad enough where I thought maybe
this is pneumonia I should see you
should see a doctor and it happened that
one of the organizers husband was a
doctor and he checked me out and he said
well the good news is is not pneumonia
the bad news is that it's Anna kidney
infection you know temperatures 104 and
you know we're gonna load you up with
some antibiotics but if you've had in a
calm you wouldn't be speaking at
Columbia on Friday you'd be in the
hospital by friday so I'm glad that that
happened and you know that if Dana is
sick and then I'm sick at listen I know
this is 2000 or 12 and I want to sound
like those 60s conspiracy conspiracy you
know conspiracy theorists but on that
first night when my fever was running
high I did have a nightmare that I was
in a hospital room and jenga who was
there with the big lad folk and a
syringe and just laughing laughing his
butt up
thank you for that introduction I do
want to say proudly that I'm actually
now a full professor here at the at the
School of the Arts and really want to
just thank again just Dean Carol Becca
and Dean Gianna right and the school of
the arts and the the Institute for
african-american research that's here
focus who on the student side really
co-sponsored and promoted this event
that stands for filmmakers of color
united in spirit can die here from focus
and the room is so full of it's almost
like if you walk around and shake hands
you're going to be like wait a minute
this book has really come to life all of
you people are real I mean I started
talking about my early experiences in a
wonderful mentoring fraternity the order
of the feather paternity is in the house
there's been great pushed by Omega
sci-fi fraternity incorporated thank you
and and and and just people that I that
I weren't sure was coming didn't know
we're coming who here people like Darrow
tuxes childhood friend and Kathleen
cleaver sister Kathleen he went we're
going to have to get it over second who
is the highest-ranking woman in the
Black Panther Party is now a law
professor between Emory and Yale my dear
dear friend now Rogers is in the house
so it's been a wonderful a terrific
journey so the book was written up after
years and years of everyone saying you
should write a book and you know you go
yeah because you know you tell a few
stories you should write a book but
would really resonated for me was when I
would travel and also my young people
and impact when they would ask the
question what was it like and they would
ask that question with a kind of passion
and fire and curiosity in the eyes that
made it clear that they wanted
understand what was it like you were 15
you were 16 you are our age what was it
like it's like we would ask one who got
to play you know in Madison Square
Garden and landed a three-pointer what
was that like at that moment at that
time and so that's what made me
understood that the voice of Panther
baby had to be of that 15 year old man
child trying to seek the path to manhood
as much as it was to what his place in
the struggle might be and those growing
pains and what happened that was good
and what happened was that was that was
bad through all of that period I'd like
to read just a section of it because it
sets up a quick conversation and the
other thing that I've been glad about is
that because it's written like that the
appearance is that that had been
happening on the book tour or Whitney
peeling is in the house my wonderful
wonderful publicist that's been working
on the book very hard and it had been
conversations not just about the book
and not just a nostalgic conversation
about what what life was like in the 60s
but what was it like what we need to be
doing today how do we continue their
conversation because many of these
problems and i'll talk about them
quickly and hopefully we can get into it
a little bit more in the in the Q&A and
this and this was really important
finding the panther layer and don't
think that i did not forget brother
bullwhip and brothership and all of the
Panthers who are in the house
Panthers you think I was going to forget
councilman charles barron is in the
house to another original Parent
Panthers did you think I was going to
forget come on now yeah I called your
name first whip I called your name first
I walked into the Panther office in
Brooklyn in September 1968 dr. King had
been assassinated in April of that year
riots and anger flared and the ghettos
around the country the feeling on the
street was that the was about to
hit the fan black Powell was the phrase
of the day hating white he was the hip
thing to do from street corner speeches
to campus rallies why'd he had gone from
being the man to being the Beast young
black students were trading in their
feel-good motown records for the
recorded speeches of Malcolm X and the
angry jazz recordings of all net Coleman
I went down to 125 street that night the
night that dr. King was assassinated
protesters in rioters swarmed the
streets clashing with cops overturning
cause setting trashcan fires and hurling
bricks at white-owned businesses one of
the store for old windows were shattered
by an airborne trashcan looters ran into
the store and started taking clothes
appliances and whatever else they could
carry not everyone looted in fact most
of the crowd continued to Chan the king
is dead and black power but it was
enough for the cops to stop swinging to
start swinging clubs shooting pistols
and making arrests a cop grabbed me and
threw me against the wall before he
could handcuff me and put me in the
paddy wagon a group of riders across the
street turn to police car over the cop
told me to stay put and ran toward the
rioters
I was scared but I wasn't stupid I took
off running in the opposite direction I
blend it in with the group of riders and
tried to figure out which way to go a
group of cops headed toward us some of
the riders ran into a clothing store
that was being looted I followed the
cops entered the store swinging clubs
and making arrests my heart pounded as I
ran into the back of the store and found
a back door leading into an alley I
gasps for air as I ran down the alley
and was stopped by a wooden fence the
cops came into the alley halt they
yelled put your hands up in my mind I
froze put my hands up and turned around
to face the cops with tears in my eyes
but my body kept hauling ass I grabbed
the fence and sprayed over the top like
a scared alley cat two shots rang out
one splinted the wood on the fence near
my butt this gave me the adrenaline push
I needed to flip over the fence pick
myself back up off the ground and
scrambled out of the alley I turned out
on the street I kept running right past
two other cops who tried to grab me but
I jerked away turning the corner almost
collided with the group of 20 or so
black men and leather coats and army
fatigue jackets wearing afros and berets
standing in military like formation stop
running young brother one of the young
one of the men with a beard in tinted
glasses said don't give these pigs an
excuse to gun you down I doubled over
heaving trying to catch my breath I
didn't know this man but his voice
sounded like a raft of confidence in a
sea of chaos moments later two cops ran
around the count ran around the corner
they stopped in front of their tracks
when they saw the militant men the men
close ranks around me what are you doing
here one of the cops demanded move aside
the black man with the tinted glasses
didn't flinch we're exercising our
constitutional right to free assembly
making sure no innocent people get
killed out here tonight which asing
looters the cops retorted
no looters here as you can see we're a
disciplined community patrol you have
guns the cops ass a change of fear in
his voice that's what you said the man
with the tinted glasses replied I said
we were exercising our constitutional
rights the cops took in the size and the
discipline of the group for a moment and
walked away by this time I caught my
breath but I was speechless from what I
had just seen black men standing on
white cops go straight home young
brother the man with the tinted glasses
said the pigs are looking for an excuse
to murder black folks tonight with that
the black men walked on i scooted down
the subway and rode home when I entered
the apartment nuni my grandmother was
sitting on the couch watching images of
dr. King on TV Kia's fell from her eyes
she'd even didn't even ask me where had
been which is unusual since I was about
two hours late getting home i sat next
to her put my arm around her and we
watched the TV reports of the
assassination and arrives
also i need to acknowledge in judge bill
mogul SQ who was a lawyer that fort so
vigorously for myself and other panthers
is in the house he was an attorney then
bill mogul SQ if y'all don't applaud i'm
going to pull up because i would not be
here my god mother Angela fontanez and
of course and of course of course of
course a primary character in the book
and in my life joyce joseph is here and
my daughter jind i Joseph and my son
Jamal joseph jr it was a few days later
that that two older friends and i headed
out to the panther office and i wanted
to be part of the most militant
organization on the scene and of course
the black panther party stood way at the
forefront they had been patrolling the
streets of Oakland California with guns
and law books they stormed the State
Capitol you know when and then when the
authorities were about to change the
laws because that the the law that said
that you could carry a gun in oakland
california as long as it wasn't
concealed and you didn't have a criminal
record but they didn't mean black guys
with leather coats and the Panthers
responded by something that we would
call a colossal event they stormed the
state capitol of sacramento and I had
you know going to school right after the
riots and I announced my friends that I
was going to be a black militant and my
buddies that always we ate lunch
together I was a hall monitor that so
there was a group of us and one of my
best friends I looked at me his name was
poor poor poor kirchner white kid a
Jewish kid and he said um any I don't
know if you can announce you're gonna be
a black militant like as a career choice
like you're gonna be a doctor or lawyer
that was like nope or you watch you
watch I'm going to be a militant so i
had to find the most militant
organization it wasn't there with the
panthers storming the state capitol of
sacramento reading the manifesto about
black people's right to defend
themselves and then the news reporter
came on and said the ultra militant
black panther party oh boy there was
that word not only militant ultra
militant and then he said in the
Panthers car was pulled over and there
were guns a communist literature down in
the trunk and i'm looking at grandma's
black and white TV and i'm going hey
crazy day crazy they got leather coats
he stormed the capital with the white
legislators they had communist
literature day so crazy i want to join
that one so we traveled to what was the
secret headquarters of the Black Panther
but we thought it was secret Costa
Panthers open community programs and
offices all over but to us it was the
secret headquarter what we were quite
getting into and on the train ride out
my older friends are trying to psych
will mainly to psych me out I guess they
thought if I got off the train they had
an excuse to yet all too so one friend
leans over he goes up you know the
Panthers is like the Mafia right once
you get in is located now I can't be a
punk in front of my boy so I'm home care
another guy leans over he says uh yo you
know you got to kill the white dude to
be a panther or kill somebody on my
honor student require boy but I got to
be tough I don't care any other friendly
Soviets nah man get it straight get it
straight you don't have to kill a white
dude I relaxed he says you gotta kill a
white cop
and you have to bring in his badge and
his gun well my my heart is pounding we
get to the panther office there's that
great black panther party sign on the
outside all these great Black Panthers
are there these brothers and sisters
with their leather coats and army
fatigue jackets and berets and some of
the sisters have their heads wrapped up
in gay leis and I sit in the back and
the Brotherhood at the front is giving
what we called a PE class political
education and he's going to the Panther
10-point program and its points like we
want freedom the power to determine the
destiny of our community full employment
for our people decent housing pick the
shelter for human beings nothing about
killing a white guy nothing about
bringing a cop's badge ago am i hearing
this no I'm still back on the train
wanting to be a man so I jump up in the
middle of him talking about the template
program and I go choose me brother Oh bi
kill away do right now Whole meeting
stops he says come here young brother
pulls open the bottom drawer of the
deaths and he reaches in and he's
reaching so far far down my heart is
pounding in my chest and I'm trying to
be cool but I'm thinking to myself look
how far he's reaching in her desk is
going to be a big day I'm going and he
comes up with a stack of books and its
soul on ice by Eldridge Cleaver the
autobiography of malcolm x wretched to
the earth by france 49 and I'm standing
there confused and I figure this must be
a test and I go brother I thought you
were gonna arm me and you see your
brother I just did
as I'm walking back to my cities a young
brother have like now work because now
I'm embarrassed it's a mask you a
question that gives you carry me here
talk about you want to kill white folks
he said of all of the cops who are out
here beating people up shooting them
down brutalizing them if they were all
black and the people being victimized
and killed were white if all of the
store owners in the community were black
and the people being ripped off with
high prices and having to deal with
rotten vegetables and spoiled me if they
were white and then he got a little path
on me he said in all these job time
demagogic fashions big politicians he
said if all of them were black and the
people being exploited in a press were
white would that make things correct at
this time I answered with a little bit
of my brain instead of my bruised ego
and I said no brother seems like it was
still be wrong he said that's right he
said this is a class struggle for human
rights not just a race struggle study
those books so you understand what the
revolution is about
and I learned the Panther Party was
bowled in that thinking they were having
a conversation about the problems in
America what they were really about that
slavery understood was a business that
the first slaves here were actually
white and the Native American and
African as the market got bigger and the
need for control that this was an
economic problem that the roots of
racism in this country was a marketing
skill for slavery for white people that
weren't sure that it was in a biblical
sin to own a slave you had white
marketeers in the slave trade saying
it's okay to own a black slave because
then I human so you're not sinning
owning the slave is like owning a horse
or a cow or a chicken and so actually
you're not sitting you're actually doing
what the Bible wants you to do which is
to work hard and prosper ingrained in
the very beginning of the American
psyche ingrained in the very beginning
of the American economic system where
the first stock traded on Wall Street
was were African slaves were the first
insurance companies made their fortunes
by ensuring slave cargoes human beings
was the dehumanization of a people and
was the victimization of the people and
it continues today this is the quickest
way to dehumanize a person is to give
them a name other than their name or
culture other than your culture and to
give them a name that allows you and an
identity that allows you to dismiss them
as your brother and your sister I was
disabused of that notion the very first
day in the Black Panther Party
and then as i was leaving afeni shakur
stop me she had been watching my whole
little performance she said how old are
you now when you're 15 years old one of
the signs that you're 15 years years old
is that by putting your age up a year
you're much older I said I'm 16 he says
you look like you about 14 or 13 years
old go home listen I want to be a black
bear I'm not gold you to go home I said
I want to be a black panther she said
well I will keep my eye on you and she
did through that experience through my
whole life and I want to say this very
very clearly to my comrades who were
there with me we served together the men
in the Black Panther Party clearly
taught me how to fight but it was the
women in the Black Panther Party who
taught me how to be a man
people see the news footage what the
media wants to continue to rent run was
those intimidating you know images of
Panther standing in front of prisons and
patrolling the streets with guns but day
to day especially a year and a half or
two and a half years into the office
what you would see our wood were women
in that organization who outnumber the
men three two one sometimes five to one
because of the attacks because of the
men of the Black Panther Party being
killed and going to jail and in key
leader position leadership positions in
all across the country and in the same
way that black women never gave up from
Middle Passage to slavery to those hard
times of the depression even till this
day when for whatever reason the men are
not home and the women never give up the
women of the Black Panther Party is the
reason why the doors of those Panther
officers stayed over they never gave up
and finally as I was leaving that first
day there was a poster that was on the
wall and it was up che guevara there was
there were there were some you know they
were great posters up there there was
though the artwork of Emory Douglas and
they were posters of eldridge cleaver
and you in newton and bobby seale but
the one that really caught my attention
was of Che Guevara and it was just hey
there and it was a quotation from a
speech that Jay had given a few years
earlier and the quotation was this at
the risk of sounding ridiculous let me
say the revolutionaries are guided by
great feelings of love and I stood there
and I read that again and again I was
like wait a minute I'm in the panther
office reading about love what's wrong
here this is what nuni always kind of
you know talked about you know even
though her parents had been slaves and
she had witnessed relatives being
lynched and she grew up in the south
where she had to step off the sidewalk
when white people came by and she'd
experience all kinds of racism
emortality she always talked about love
and dr. King talked about it
menacing the youth program that I grew
up in it they talked about lucky I'm in
the panther office and they're talking
my love and yes it is about the real
foundational strength of any struggle
that you do it because of love for the
people now any Panther will tell you
that if you ask if we're asked what was
it really about for you what was it
really about for you not the 10-point
program and all of the books that you
read by you know by Fidel and by phone
on and by Marx and Lenin and all of the
ideology of the Black Panther Party if
there was one thing that you had to say
that motivated you was a panther they
will answer the question like this
guaranteed we were taught to have an
undying love for the people we return to
taught to serve the people mind body and
soul and so as we started the breakfast
programs and health clinics and the
liberation schools and the clothing
programs that community service because
we learn from the civil rights movement
that you organize people around their
needs it's very good and I like to say
this to my to my friends on the left and
to my brave young comrades who are part
of the Occupy movements across the
country that you have to organize people
around their needs when you talk about
freedom and liberation these are
abstract concepts to people struggling
to survive day to day freedom to someone
who was starving as a meal liberation to
someone who's shivering homeless is a
dry safe warm place to sleep and so when
we saw that our children were saying
that they were telling our children oh
you're underperforming you know black
children are learning what we said well
you know what it's hard for black kids
to go into school and learn arithmetic
with the teacher telling them that two
apples plus three apples equal five
apples and their stomachs are growling
we need to start a community program to
do this and with no money but going to a
church basement going to a church can we
use your basement can we use the dining
room going to a community center and
then so we had a place to prepare the
food
and in going to store owners in the
community and not asking for money but
will you give us a case of pancake mix
that the store owner across the street
has given us a case of note the store on
the down the street has given us a case
of eggs we can feed some kids Panthers
would come out and cook and then
grandmothers and mothers would come out
and cook and we started the first week
maybe with 50 kids and in a month that
became 500 kids their kids today they
come up and says I was fed in that
breakfast program I got healed in that
health clinic no money as a doctor or
nurse to come and volunteer a Saturday
bring some medicine help heal the
community and people responded to that
and when people would come into the
community seeking to attack and to
vilify the Black Panther Party would be
though saying grandmother's and says I
can't even pronounce some of the words
terrorists all that what you're saying
but I know they feed my babies I know I
get my diabetes medicine from them I
know that they care so it's on that
ground organizing that we hope that
people remember that having rallies is a
great thing we have to affect policy but
we have to remember it is about the
people and that you organize people
around your needs that's love it's love
that makes you get up at four o'clock in
the morning when it's cold to feed kids
that are not your kids it's love that
makes you when your legs are aching from
a day of organizing that makes you get
off the bus to help that grandmother
eight flights up in her walk up with her
bags and then back down and it's love
that makes you get back off that bus
when we were Panthers and stand between
a cop who has their gun drawn on a black
person and stand between that gun and
that cop and we don't know that person
but we understand that's our brother and
sister and if we don't stand maybe
nobody will stand that's revolutionary
love
so I don't have to keep my remarks to
leave sometimes for the for the question
in the audience but it is so I'm so
grateful for the night and I'm so
grateful to to be able to stand here
truly and what's truly a family reunion
I mean some people talk about that and
they get the family to come out but from
every aspect of my life from the time
that I was growing up in the North Bronx
to being a professor here at Columbia
University now and I'll just close with
the story I have to tell this one
because it really sums it up you know as
Colombia used to be the place that would
throw down like instantly when something
would go right for for our Columbia
faculty and alumni remember those times
are something would happen they would
shut it down and keep in mind when we're
talking about repression and we go back
to the time when j edgar hoover
testified against the Black Panther
Party before Congress in 1968 where he
called the Black Panther Party the
greatest threat to the internal security
of America this is interesting people
research this you know what bothered him
the mouse it wasn't a socialist rhetoric
it wasn't the guns it was the free
breakfast program to him this was the
most insurgent thing that we were doing
was feeding kids in reaching in reaching
communities and the response to the
government against student protests
nevermind what happened to the Black
Panther Party the arrest of the Panther
21 the murder of Fred Hampton to shoot
out in LA the bombing of our officers
never mind that never mind that but on
college campuses when students were
standing up national guards and
sheriff's were murdering students
murdering students I remember giving the
speech at 17 years old because students
in Mississippi State had been killed and
then students in kent state had been
killed and I said that America and
pretty sure this is what I said to a
crowd that America will murder any nigga
who stands up but what Kent State shows
us is that
as far as America is concerned anybody
who stands up as a nigga because they
kill those white students in cold blood
so we have to understand that if we
don't understand that we're one if we
don't understand in the spirit of all
power to the people meaning black power
to black people white powder white
people red power to read people brown
power to brown people yellow powder
yellow people that the system
understands that and so we've got to
organize around our needs but we also
need to communicate is no accident that
this room is such a multicultural room
right now and such a crosswalk of
professions and lives and talent so I
urge people that I thank you for coming
out but get to know what other because
this is the energy energy that it will
take to make human transformation thank
you so much
so I'm going to ask jamal just a couple
of questions and then we'll open it up
to the audience but but the first
question I'm going to start with that
intrigued me in the book is is about
revolution because at one point you're
talking about debate that you were
having in the party about how soon
revolution would come would it be within
a year three years five years ten years
so so talk to us about that well we you
know we we were young people you know I
was one of the babies of the movement
because i joined the panther party at 15
but that day in the panther office are
the people who in the office were 17 18
19 years old uh I think the average age
of a panther was about 20 years old so I
I think I was 15 when I was joining now
what were you 16 where's now Rogers it
not enough now Rogers was 16 charles
barron what were you about 16 years old
are you 18 boo of how are you okay you
were Olga and this but then you then
when you came other places like for
example here on the campus of Columbia
uh there there were young people from
SDS and there was a young Lords party
and there was a group in New York or you
walk home which was the harmonious fist
so one of the great things that would
happen is that before and after those
rallies in takeovers you would sit and
you would talk about what were you need
to the struggles of different
communities and you listen to each other
so you came back to the black community
talking about women's rights talking
about what was happening in the Asian
community the Latino community uh and so
one night after a takeover in Columbia
we were hanging out right here in one of
the dorm rooms and we started getting
into this heated debate young people
about how long the revolution would take
we won't figure out right there that
night
one guy said three years who like you
pessimistic you reaction there he hasn't
gonna be we debated on and on into the
night and finally about three in the
morning we said well after all this is
the heart and soul of the
military-industrial complex it's going
to take ten years and we declared it and
figured it out but it was the feeling
that change was going to come the youth
movement and the anti-war movement did
in the war in Vietnam arm I think what
we underestimate was just how viciously
the government will respond and you
can't have a conversation about the
Black Panther Party in fact about all
progressive movements without talking
about the FBI's counterintelligence
program COINTELPRO and what Cohen so did
in terms of infiltrating organizations
turning members against one another
planting false evidence ruining people's
lives all with the blessing of Congress
up and in even the conflicts a lot of
the things that happened between local
panther chapters and local police
departments was at the manipulation of
COINTELPRO by using their insiders and
the counterintelligence saying is like
we can get you some weapons you better
arm up because the police are getting
ready to come and then taking that very
same attend the very same intelligence
to the police department saying the
Panthers are building up they're getting
ready to attack you better do a
preemptive strike so on all sides not
only were lawyers were laws violated
lies were lost and ruined so on this
point of agents provocateurs can you
take us and describe the moment when
your mentor yet wha when you discover
that he wasn't who he who you thought he
was but you also mentioned that if a
neat actually knew or had a sense that
he was working for the cops or the CIA
whomever yeah yeah wahhhh was someone
that we described
as a crazy brother so he was that
Panther that you know if we were at a
rally in the cops were advancing he'd
rushed i had and starts shoving and
swinging and want to take them on if we
were helping to organize a building in
harlem by showing the tenants how to do
a rent strike and how to make put the
money in escrow and make the repairs and
then you know get some landlord tenant
lawyers to represent them he'd be like
well where does the landlord live let's
go find his mansion and burn it down and
to the young brothers this was very
exciting but if any would say you know
why are you doing it this is kind of
like you don't pushing it just is like
agent provocateur stuff and you know but
you would you gravitated toward that
swagger and you know he made sure he was
my section leader this was like your
sergeant or your lieutenant in the Black
Panther Party and he made sure that I
you know knew the 10-point program and
memorize the other stuff and showed up
for the community programs even came to
my house when my grandmother frustrated
that I was too busy to clean my room and
wasn't doing my chores when she did all
of that she you know she did what you
know a lot of parents in the room dues
went to straighten up my room and down
hidden underneath my bed all of this
Black Panther material I came home that
night and it was a stack of Panther
papers and books and 11 and there was
the Holy Bible and then it was a bell
that was the Mafia also I didn't see it
independent and if you see the Panther
papers they had that great work by Emory
Douglas where the cops would be
portrayed like pigs you know wouldn't
flies buzzing around their head and
you've had the African show you know
African schoolchildren looking very
sweet and innocent with books over one
shoulder an ak-47 under the other solar
and I came in and she had all of this
stuff and just was waiting for me and
she said boy what is this I said grandma
you weigh in my room she said not not
I'm she said what is this she said
because I don't know whether to bless
you with this but I don't know whether
to bless you with his belt or kill you
with this Bible but you're not going
back and as my sexually he came up and
convinced her let me go back he said
ma'am if he doesn't go back and you know
the right words to say because he said
whatever you decide is fine because
you're his grandmother you're my elder
but I know he's not doing well in school
I'll keep an eye on and make sure his
grades go up I'll make sure he makes his
curfews and she let me go back four
weeks later the door of grandmas
apartments kicked in at four in the
morning and I was arrested in the
Panther 21 case and as the lawyers
fought and fought and fought two to find
out what the case was really about under
the rules of discovery we found out that
that two of the key witnesses were
undercover cops they were part of a unit
here in New York that was known as the
boss unit the Bureau of Special Services
one of those men was jean-robert's who
had been Malcolm X's bodyguard in fact
when Malcolm was shot he was a few feet
away in fact when Malcolm was breathing
his last breaths jean-robert's was given
in the mouth to mouth resuscitation he
was an undercover cop so those
credentials he came into the Black
Panther Party became a security
lieutenant and the other deeply place
cop was yay whoa my mentor so you talk
about our deceit you talk about betrayal
all of those buildings there was a
mixture of confusion and heartbreak and
rage because
remember I never met my dad found out
years in late years later but my debt
that my dad actually fought alongside of
pidele castro and che guevara and became
a general in Cuba's military and Cuba's
in that bastard or two to Tanzania and
grandpa had died a few years younger so
it was so much about the path of manhood
as much as it was about the politics so
I want to go there for those of us that
didn't know you before the book I had no
idea about your Cuban roots much less
that your biological father was a Cuban
revolutionary and it later in the book
you speculate about the DNA but you
wonder if you have this revolutionary
DNA right and on the other hand as you
said tonight it was it was the women in
the party that taught you how to be a
man and I have to give a shout out to
Kathleen cleaver who's here because
professor professor cleaver was my
professor in grad school I took a class
with her called the law of slavery and
anti-slavery which taught me a lot as
your opening remarks did brother Jamal
but I want to know I want to know the
role can you I want to talk about gender
for a minute in the party which is often
a controversial question so as you
describe that you said the women were
doing they were keeping the offices open
they were doing the work the
organizational work of keeping the party
alive yes what say more about the
lessons you learn from the women in the
party about masculinity about being a
man and how did those differ from what
you were learning from your male Mentors
how are those lessons go one and two
it's really important at you know and
there's another strong sister house
wasn't it wasn't in the Panther Party
but been part of the movement and and
embodies this energy ebony Joe and I
have to have to have to acknowledge
sister Avenue
but um but but the sisters would make it
clear when we talk about these community
programs it was the sisters who kind of
kept us in check about what we needed to
do so a lot of the conversations and a
lot about this community programming
taking care of the kids was important
and a lot of sisters making it clear
that that you know we need to learn how
to operate those shotguns in those
rifles to protect the family at night
and you brothers need to learn how to
make these pancakes and change these
diapers to help raise the family during
the day and this needs to be the
hardware soul of this organization so
understanding that at first you resented
it I think and then you came to love
that part of your service which was the
majority of your day in the Black
Panther Party and I had to say it was
the soul of those sisters and in a very
principled way talking about what the
organization but was about and what the
struggle was about making it clear to us
what I work needed to be you know I one
of the people from the Occupy movement
young people was was at an event in
Seattle and she says you know there's
some of them some people in the movement
who are getting restless and he want to
deal with more on confrontation i said
you know and and i was talking about the
community aspect of it in the
organization and i said when i say that
to people they kind of looking to go
well and I understand that's not
glamorous that's not sexy but if the
Panther Party who really had to swaggin
and no one had more talk about
revolution and armed struggle if the
Panthers understood two things that one
that you organize people around you
their needs and to that even if your
goal is to come to that place of armed
struggle that if you go there before the
community is ready that community that
you're supposed to be representing will
hate you because what would happen to
poor communities cops would roll in with
tanks and with guns and Bob wise and
people would have to stop be carrying
our ID cards and check and it would be
all this frisk oh wait a minute am I
talking about nineteen sixty eight or
but your real job is to raise the
consciousness of the people and that's
done around issues that they that they
really care about and let me just also
say our colleague Alondra Nelson who
teaches here in sociology and women and
gender studies has a book out body and
soul all about the health and medical
programs of the party yes so a must-read
last question from me what's the
relevance of the 10-point platform today
under a black president who's not Bobby
Seale the 10-point program kind of
remains one of the most articulate dark
documents about about needs in a poor
community it was written specifically
about the black community but other
organizations adopted it had points and
platforms that were similar the young
Lords party did the Patriot party which
was a white organization that was
founded in Baltimore did sadly it was
written and we and I'm i think the
version you should try to look for in
line as the october 1966 version so
that's forty some odd years ago sadly it
could have been written two years ago
because most of the things in the
temporary program have not been
addressed when you talk about education
when you talk about community control
when you talk about employment when you
talk about police brutality you know we
have this resurgent and certainly when
you talk about before we open this up I
want to linger on this just for a second
the mass incarceration of young black
and brown men when I served time in
prison I and I served a total of nine
and a half years most of the prison's
there were were black and brown men
black and brown women economics it goes
back to economics goes like support
communities not having good legal
defense and all of that goes back to
this other tier of slavery as we talked
about it
America was number three in the amount
of people that had had locked up behind
the then soviet union and south africa
about four or five hundred thousand
people locked up now today
unquestionably number one with over two
million people locked up tell me what's
wrong with that picture 700,000
stop-and-frisk here in New most of them
black and brown boys that now get their
name in the dead in a database not uh
not a lot of them leading you leading to
arrest ninety percent of those
stop-and-frisk don't lead to arrest tell
me what's wrong with that picture
institutes that do studies to study 3rd
and 4th grade reading scores in poor
neighborhoods to determine how many
prisons to build in five years in New
York City 75 to 80 percent a brother
Barron I might that number might be low
but seventy five to eighty percent of
the black and brown boys who are locked
up come from 5 zip codes 5 zip codes to
in Harlem one and Brooklyn all from
pouring black communities and what do we
do it about our response prisons is
fetishize it's a reality TV show should
i watch lockup raw or should I wash up
San Quentin live where we see police
guard of what they call Special Response
Teams BTW people down and beating them
into submission and we come with that
well i think the answer to it is and by
the way the programs that i was the
beneficiary of of where i earn degrees
from from the university of kansas and
graduated with honors and it's a real
degree i trust me my chain hawk is my
Jayhawk is not behind you know he
doesn't have on a baseball cap behind
bars won't be deaf
those programs don't exist anymore right
counterintuitive to everything to every
study that shows you that the rate of
recidivism lowers proportionate to the
amount of education so community I say
that we have to fight that we have to
create roadblocks to jail and pathways
to Yale without young black and brown
boys and of course to columbia and to
morgan state and to Morehouse and to
City College because we know that that's
the antidote in the answer but that
takes outrage and organization and by
the way the last thing of this and this
goes back to to the community efforts to
my brothers and sisters who fight
valiantly on the front line for prison
reform if this to minyan our prison two
million people locked up mainly of color
men and women how many children of
prisoners are going on mentored multiply
that number and no we have to be doing
the work the record with those young
people
when a so please come to her right there
if you have a short question as in a
short question in a short answer the
short answer is it how you doing brother
Jamal hey how are you I just wanted to
say that you've done something that Paul
Robeson John I would kill him and other
Davis did they marry somebody most
farted in him yes that's exactly play
that's exactly right that's right that
was short and sweet and I have no
comment except he's a thousand percent
right that's the answer i doing my name
is noche I'm one of the people who's
fighting against mass incarceration
today i patrol the streets out here
grant projects just down the block and
one thank you I wanted Judas two things
if you could address you spoke about
COINTELPRO and the targeted the
leadership of the Panthers and the
struggles could you also speak as you
did state about mass incarceration
because Carl dicks was going to be
speaking tomorrow I Riverside is going
to is argues that mass incarceration
developed in part as a response to that
whole generation in order to you know
target their communities black and
Latino communities to prevent the kind
of uprisings that happen in the 60s and
70s yeah very quickly I totally agree
with that and um and with that analysis
you know that there's a there's a book
out that talks about how go and tell pro
targeted Tupac because to park was so
political and was that you was already
healing those fractures you know between
the East Coast West Coast and then if
people are not fighting each other who
are they fighting that becomes a
revolutionary force Fred Hampton was
killed in large part because of his work
with the gangs in Chicago
because he was organizing them into a
progressive force so if this is a
hundred thousand gang members and they
start to understand state oppression and
that they should be defending and
serving the community then we are those
hundred thousand guns turn to if not at
each other so that lethal potential
force of an educated progressive
nationwide army of young black and brown
men that are educating you know when we
were in the prisons we turned them into
liberation schools become something that
I believe that the system wants to
diffuse before it can either begin to
become that gathering storm hey Jamal my
name is Bruce Lincoln so I want to ask
the question and it's a collective idea
that I'm proposing where do we go from
here how do we take the tents
temperatures outline from the Panther
Party make them relevant to what we need
to do within the context of where we are
now in a 21st century oh I think that's
great what Bruce don't walk away give us
I think that's a good question and I
think for answers of that and gathering
is a following for that do you have a
web address or website that you think
that we can respond to to respond to
those ideas because I think that was
that was a question and an answer into
itself I think we have to think tank it
I think that the only thing I'll say to
that is that I think it happens on three
levels and I think yes policy right so
that we are empowering progressive
politicians and maybe not so progressive
to make it a quick story that Harry
Belafonte tells is that is that a
Phillip Randolph was the grave greatest
labor organizing history comes to the
White House and President Truman gathers
his whole staff and he says you know his
whole cabin he said I want you to listen
to this man this is a bright man and I
went in a brilliant man and an honest
man I listened to his ideas and and mr.
Randolph lays out the case of black
labor and the labor movement brilliantly
and after was done President Truman says
I agree with everything that you said
this is important
I need you to get into the street and
make me do it you see where me well that
was Roosevelt yeah that was Roosevelt he
said now I need you to get into the
street and make me do it and so it has
to be you know has to be policy it has
to be the master organizing but it also
has to be grassroots which is the
mentoring in the community program so
for those ideas and for that to feedback
on those things where can we come to you
have some place that can be like a
general dropbox and no come on you the
digital to the digital god ok so it's so
for now please say is you know I work
with a group that Dorian's also involved
with the Center for social inclusion so
I think it's important that we bring
science to how we're now addressing
policy I think so that we can bring in
where there's new opportunities for
philanthropy Apple ism we look at the
civil rights movement our quest for
liberation and the social venture then
we can leverage this University
Columbia's unique history in terms of
being involved in this and there's lots
of resources here right now so I'm
thinking you know that's sort of what we
need to do but it has to first get based
on the fact that there's a knowledge
base that we have in Harlem that's a
continuum that makes tremendous sense
how do we now apply that to all these
sort of issues I mean I'm working from
the Social Venture side where it's
persons like myself who you know
entrepreneurs we found out how do we
address this from an entrepreneurial
standpoint and we forgot ways to raise
monies in those very place where back in
the day or even today they're figure out
how to build prisons right so but I
think it has to get uppers ya know I
wouldn't even know no it's cool so I'll
tell you what would I think it's to
continue the universe here drives it
from someone such as yourself right so
again it's got to connect just to
facilitate the conversation oh thanks to
to mike l Washington ISM and some other
good people have a website is Mike
helen-alice yeah so dropped me there's a
website called Jamal Joseph com there's
an email address on that drop ideas for
continuing the conversation there and
we'll try to sort out and see if we can
follow up with ongoing conversations
so in the interest of time let's take 3
comments and then have Professor Joseph
responded are there some sisters that
want to ask a question we got too much
testosterone appear let's take
everybody's comment and then with the
stuff everybody has their down okay yes
yes I've been talking about it a lot
there wasn't time tonight but it was so
important and of course this is who I am
now a progressive artist and that work
was done by people like amiri baraka
sonia sanchez during the 60s and
understanding that art also had 20 and
wait a minute there's a little artist
named Henry Douglas that was brought in
the Black Arts Movement and
understanding that the only culture were
worth keeping is a revolutionary culture
and then learned in prison the
transformative power in the
revolutionary power of art so very
important absolutely so let's keep
trying to take comments really wouldn't
try to do one closing really quickly
because we impact us impact is up y'all
want to see impact don't you okay peace
Jamal and this is not really a question
for you because I can see the fruits of
your labor through the babies up there
that impact is and the powerful impact
no pun intended that makes from the
community my question to everybody here
because I take a look around and I don't
really see the youth besides the youth
up there my question is how can you
connect empower inspire enhance the
development of the young people in the
community who are the tomorrow's today's
yesterday that we're seeing now how can
you do that through your actions without
the judgment of the kids wearing their
pants down to their ankles and to the
teenage babies how can you do that
that's my question to you very good
thank you for that how many come in
common yeah
for the Jamal my brother I'm just here
to let you know we in the house from the
townhouse to you and you just keep doing
right on what you're doing and we got
your back power to thank you brother
danke a shell on Italian otoko in RP the
toy unit I don't patello Nina CSUN okay
initiative in an opener brother Dean
Jamal Joseph oh thank you you have a st.
Croix connection this is high oh thank
you so much that's chief okie know by
the way chief okie know who is a
brilliant leader of not only of Native
people here up and down the east coast
for the brilliant scientist peace
brother home if we have time can just
take a moment and I talk about your
personal sacrifices that you have
suffered or that you have gone through
as a result of making a choice at the
age of 15 to be to be dedicated towards
the freedom and upliftment of our people
okay we'll try it out try to put that in
the wrap up yes I think we I think
people on if you're not on the lines mom
or pam pam has to agree yeah you're the
last person sister Pam I saw his Panther
sister did I was like I was going to say
before but now I can that's a panther
sister go ahead all right how much of
you mentioned that your father wasn't
really in your life how much of a
difference do you think that your father
would have had if he was there for you
I'm fully understand assistant like how
much of a difference do you think your
father would have had in your life if he
was there you know it's hard to know um
how much of a difference I hear great
things about him but it's just hard to
know but I know that not having a father
made my journey of not only trying to be
a personally a good father to to my
children but to mentor and to be there
for as many young people as I can over
the years really important
yeah can we can we I don't I didn't want
to ignore the guys who want Dominic
where did you go and Dominic boys okay
Dominic got new really needs your
comment come back please yeah go ahead
Pam hi Jamal I was 14 when I joined oh
yes he did we're good okay having been a
political prisoner been fortunate enough
to be released how what are your
thoughts on how COINTELPRO has ruined
all those lives that are still behind
the walls I'd like to use for you to
dressing well those lives continue to be
destroyed when you talk about people
like boobie abu-jamal when you talk
about say cool dinga Sundiata okole who
continue to be leaders in prison but
have had to in the best way they could
try to be fathers and husbands from
behind the vols we're talking about
lives in lifetimes of law and concentric
circles that have been affected by by
what COINTELPRO did we really have to
end it there please join me in thanking
professor joseph or a stimulating
do not do not do not do not go anywhere
give us one minute to clear the stage so
we can see and hear impact